nine eight seven
six five four three
two one zero
i just realized i was muted okay
i think we're good right hopefully we're
good
oh i'm playing game over bro
but the game is just beginning bro
okay oh same rating too oh wow
yeah game over pro is a good player
um let's manage time
also good luck good luck to everyone um
this is an arena format so people can
join
and leave whenever
i have to stay somewhat focused here
let's go for this idea
i played the same kind of setup against
sagar shah
aligned against f pawn
put the rook in
okay i'm just trying to manage my time
and keep the position stable
it should be slightly better here
but these positions they they tend to
lead to
like very long games
and black is solid black one connect
four
i might want to take at some point open
the d file
like a bishop here i take in rook d7
okay so we'll put the pawn there
now c5 is a good move
i'm probably taking bishop d5
it's a nice bishop
okay can't complain um
everything is kind of just under control
it's not clear how lock develops
again bishop here i take in rook d7
um
it's a respectable move
let's take and play e5 just opening the
square for the
[Music]
queen
okay i'm losing a pawn
[Music]
but i mean the pieces are good
it's still a question how i make
progress
oh here i can take go after this phone
i'm rookie is a threat too
okay some people already starting with
the berserk win
now if you like to like win this
tournament i'm gonna need to berserk a
lot of games
but this is the first step
okay so rook d7 queen c5
let's do it
and there's this crazy move it's
actually a really cool move
because the bishop's pinned to the
mating square
pawn and now this pawns attacked this
pawn's attacked
the bishop's no longer defended
okay this worked out yeah that worked
out beautifully
okay let's go playing douglas hayne
um yeah so for those not familiar
berserking is when you
[Music]
basically give time odds but
a win in this game will will not mean
one more tournament points
okay staff for gamba time let's go
opponent seems prepared
everyone's playing probably the best
variation
but i'm prepared too
yeah this is like the magical jonathan
tron sign
uh oh i don't think anyone has ever
played this move which
it's just kind of a blunder because uh
that pawn is pinned
hey karasu morgan welcome back
thanks for gifting subs okay this is
working out really well
why you played such a good good opening
too at least the first several moves
uh let's develop a bishop
oh no my bishop ah
i guess i could have taken the pawn but
i don't think box or white's gonna take
here
rook d8 would be the counter
wait now my my bishop and my knight are
hanging
um
what to do
what to do i have queen g5
let's fight knight f4 now my bishop is
actually
just hanging
uh but if i takes it i'll have some
hopefully some fun along the d file
okay so g5 threatening bishop g4
there we go
i'm going to win the bishop on e2
throw in the check lost my first game
cos of misclicking oh no
oh no you'll bounce back togi
just keep believing in yourself and
don't miss click oh my time
okay let's focus up a piece here
i think it's kind of in the meaning that
it's tricky move
okay just give my king some room
it should be a straightforward win
going for this move
yeah this is a very common mating
pattern
and white can't stop uh the main on e2
there's some spike checks
oh okay i think that was a mouse slip
okay let's go uh top ten
yeah the leader has three wins
so 35 minutes left not too late to join
let's berserk again okay
let's play i'll play a ponziani this
time
on c3
first ponziani of the stream
now this is one of the main lines
i'm pressuring the file kind of losing
upon
and the hope would be to get some
compensation
i probably probably should have defended
that though
that's knight before i have bishop g5
okay so i'm down upon i just missed a
tactic too i still have the same tactic
yeah the pawn was overworked here so if
takes i
i win the bishop so it's back to equal
material
and positions really nice now so i have
the file
[Music]
play h4
yeah position's nice i just have to
watch my time
maybe f4 or even
this move because the bishop's pinned to
the rook
bishop's out also attacked four times
okay now three times
oh that's a good move
okay but now i'm winning the pawn
there's still some fight left
but it's difficult for black like
there's one there's only one move i see
here
to try and keep fighting
i was thinking rook here oh that's a
move too
this is now a
threat so i have i can take
and bishop c5 would be a blunder because
king here
i'll probably walk the king up
like he wants to be on g4 weirdly enough
i might end up winning this game on time
but we'll see
uh take let's play kenji for defending
the pawn
getting ready to win this pawn
oh there's some really funny mating idea
to play f5 knight h8
rook takes g6 king goes back and then
mates
yeah knight h8 is coming it's not force
mates but
um yeah i guess
black didn't take the knights it's still
really close to mate
there we go okay that was nice
let's go oh game over bro is ahead of me
what
where am i oh i'm still top 10.
i just have to win games more quickly i
guess i've been having longer games than
some other people
okay scandi time
so this is a kind of pet gamut line
i like to play whoa it's morick
you guys put yourselves out there with
all this free content glad to be able to
support
thanks so much oh support it
i really appreciate that donating 15
oh i should have played i should have
played um
rook b1
okay this is still playable there's some
comp here
moving quickly should try and keep the
pace
winning back upon
winning a night now
if i take
let's play this move go for 94.
actually queen a5 could be annoying i'll
castle
yeah queen a5 was an idea there
but now it's no longer a big concern
could even i'll save the bishop
oh wait my night's hanging oops
that wasn't good at my time
that was that was really not good
yeah it's still close to winning
actually
play this move first
this move
oh no my knight and my bishop and my
pawn everything's hanging
ah and my actually my time is probably
the worst
out of everything that's bad
okay this is the whole idea to just meet
actually it's still tricky though
i have to go for the additional mates
rook b8 would have been very strong
there
that it's i think it's mating next move
black should have slowed down a little
bit there
okay that worked out nicely
i could have very easily just lost that
game on time
so um i've only played four games
is it not refreshing
i guess i've only played four games
okay so i'm in oh i'm in third place
let's go i'll keep beserking i'm going
to try and win my own viewer tournament
playing against a vienna
i'll play this line i played this
against lavi the other day
um yeah this is playable
this is kind of a funny move
okay uh so i want a piece
now unlike the previous game i'm going
to try and i convert this smoothly
i'm going for the the pin and win
slowly but surely
or quickly but surely
so idea is to swing over
and just get a lot of attack on the king
side
um
[Music]
okay so the bishop kind of repositioned
itself it's no longer pinning the knight
but it's going to help target the pawn
also this pawn is a target
yeah i mean the thing about the sort of
position i'm up a piece and just have
way more attackers okay
first place let's go the first time
being in first place
um i'm gonna try and keep the the streak
been berserking every game i guess since
the second game
and yeah thanks to everyone who's
playing i know that's uh it's a big
turnout
this might be like the biggest viewer
tournament i've
ever run oh i forgot to berserk
i would have berserked but i guess now i
can try and just win games
um okay it's another staffer gambit
so yeah this is an interesting variation
like a lot of people will play h3
or c3 before castling
am i knight
okay yeah i was writing meat uh
made in one g3 it looks like it blocks
and mates
the problem is the f pawn is pinned
um so one funny thing about this
this exact line is
if you go to my youtube channel
also i've completely forgot i scheduled
a video
yeah my most recent video i i guess was
scheduled during the stream
but if you sort videos by most popular
[Music]
my most popular video has almost three
million views
and it's the same opening trap
that i just had like this g3 queen takes
g3
and a lot of the comments on the video
are
asking why the pawn can't take like
clearly
yeah the bishop pins okay so
i had to show that because in these days
not too many people fall for the trap
anymore
because so many people have seen the
video okay playing a
decently high rated player
tamo jerry
okay let's play one of these
opponent knows what they're doing
she blocks really well prepared here
trying to remember the line i think 95.
i'm kind of forgetting
i think i already maybe messed it up
it's still playable i think
hear this move
idea if queen here here i play c3 and
eventually knight c5
this move maybe whoa it's a rain hey
it's are we supposed to
i heard you were streaming thanks for
sending the raid
hope you had a good stream shout out to
are we supposed to
who i played i played hand in brain with
earlier on gary stream
okay if you're just joining i have to
speed things up
moving way too slowly here also if
you're just joining i'm doing a viewer
tournament
everyone is free to join you can use the
join command
um it's a tricky move let's take
oh it's bits thanks so much it's been a
while
it has alexa
it's been a while hi
hi
don't hurt me
queen e3 expected
or no let's play this
move
so i'm winning material but i'm about to
flag
what okay that worked out
much love eric oh much love
thanks for the love
no
no i was completely winning i got dirty
flagged
because i'm so slow good game
tamil jerry oh such a good position
too okay
all good things must come to an end
until they're reborn so i'll try and
i'll try and get another streak i guess
also yeah shout out to are we supposed
to i don't know
if anyone gave you a shout out
but people should check out are we
supposed to on twitch
okay let's berserk so now i'm tilted
kind of
i'm gonna play some tilt openings
you oh that's me
thanks for studying um
let's take whoa it's another rain it's
angelica chasborne
appreciate that um
if you're just joining i'm a little bit
flustered from the
the last game i played maybe i can play
this move in bishop c3
trying to trade off black's best bishop
and i have six was good
okay
i just got to play quick quick moves
oh yeah shout out to angelico chessborne
really appreciate the rain
um for those joining i'm doing a viewer
tournament
the link to it is in the chat free to
join
it's an arena tournament there are
about 18 minutes left
i'm trying to win it like i just got
passed by tamil jerry
um yeah this could be tough
really going to have to speed things up
and probably play more aggressively too
put the rook on d1 let's not get mated
yeah rook d1 would have been tragic
there
okay so saving the king
and the queen is very much a target here
some knight b3
pawn is also kind of a target
the thing is like box king is so solid
it's going to be hard to attack okay e6
kind of weakens at night
so the plan is to play queen g5
okay let's trade
i'm really not sure what my plan is
and bring the knight here
some h4 remove
black's playing well oh never mind
uh black played really well up until
laundering a queen
maybe i have to do more of that just
compliment my opponents play
and give them a false sense of
confidence
okay so elba queen time is leveling out
uh yeah let's take the the thing
okay let's go no time to waste so i i
leapfrogged tamo jerry again
but tamil jerry on a streak wind
berserking oh tamo jerry's in trouble
though
so i'm rooting for paiser but paiser's
in third place
i'm gonna get passed by one of these
players
so waiting for another game trying to
defend my
pride and honor
to stay focused let's take a pawn
yeah so i want a pawn
i'm just trying to hold on to the center
yeah this is a nice opening
that was a good move actually
this could get weird takes takes takes
i guess takes takes my pawn might
survive on g2
or not
but it might so it's probably bad for
white to take it
nope white took it
oh but it was bad for white to take it
because this move
pinning the queen to the king and
basically winning the exchange
okay so i'm i'm gonna probably win the
pawn
uh except maybe not
because 96 so i have g5
wait my time is low
that's a free night
there we go okay let's go so i won a
game
um oh go cool go cool with a berserk
yeah a lot of people with like these
massive berserking streaks so
i'm gonna have to speed things up
about gokul berserking a a decently high
rated player
okay mr blunder
um let's play something normal
okay
i'm gonna try and be aggressive here
oh no my pawn
here i can probably take and
[Music]
it's also this move eventually i want to
take and
play g4 i can play this right away
actually
we could trade
here we go
yeah attacking with all the pieces
yeah okay uh was going for the quick
meet their appointment missed it
let's go
okay berserking no slowing down
um maybe we'll play let's play a fun
gamut
oh let's play center fork trick a lot of
people getting hit with
the center fork trick oh now it's a
stafford
wait my my opponent's now playing a
stafford um
let's just move back it's like a weird
move order so it's not a true stafford
and i'll get a nice kind of pawn center
yeah the very mobile pawn center
e5 is eventual idea
um yeah that's a good move
so my bishop's just kind of chilling so
if black ever takes that h file opens
black should probably have taken it at
some point there
yeah my queen is gonna be surviving
okay let's be civil all right c4 first
defending the pawn and now the g file's
open
yeah i can go for the quick mating
attack
unleashing this bishop
i'm trying to provoke knight e4
okay
i probably could have taken that pawn a
few moves ago
here we go
okay that was nice so now
okay i'm unclear first trying to extend
my lead
goku is close behind
but in the midst of a game
okay let's go or berserking let's play
in england
playing a two 2007.
let's play quick
interesting
doh my knights ah and white could fork
me too
oh but white's not falling for my
trickiness
that's unfortunate
yeah too many people know it
it's unfortunate okay so
i'm down upon why wants to meet me
i guess i have to play g6
yeah white really wants to meet me
that's a scary position
i'm just gonna like turtle up on the
king side
there's some idea knight e5 to g4 and
then
target the queen
what is this move i think maybe white
wanted to do this but
um yeah that was a nice gift i'm
actually threatening
oh i'm threatening nike for trapping the
queen
okay so now i can
[Music]
i guess white will win the night
okay we're gonna trade everything i'll
be up a bishop
for i'll put bishop for three pawns
preventing light from castling in the
end game
i actually forgot counseling was legal
there
uh let's play this oh my bishop no
okay white's white's being very good at
not taking
pieces that aren't actually free
oh and white's gonna win the pawn
[Music]
oh that's unfortunate wait this is going
to take work
because i'm nowhere close to winning now
and i only have 18 seconds left
that's annoying move
the good thing is
there's some prospect of playing bishop
here
that's meat wow that's meat um
few things to note there i i did have
this move which is maybe more precise
because i could have played this but
then this
anyway okay so i got the mating attack
i'm i had by five points overall
simon i think i'm in good shape good
morning eric
good morning josh jackson thanks for
subbing
for six months okay playing theo couts
so this could be the last game
actually oh white moose first i forgot
i was waiting for my opponent to move
let's play a halloween halloween gambit
declined halloween gambit is usually
something you should not decline
okay gonna be super aggro
push all the pawns or at least most of
the pawns
i missed a fork okay i'm trapping my
rook
it still works out
the goal is to get one more game after
this
the goal is also to get a smothered mate
somehow
it might be more difficult
we might end up trading queens
okay so i'm unleashing the rook oh
google's tied with me
what oh no okay i need to i really need
to finish this game then
i could have won the okay here we go
let's go back to tournament no time to
waste so goku needs to win
uh could be close
so i'm playing a hillbilly attack it's a
fun opening
if goku wins like berserk wins and we
we're tied
so i'm just trying to play like super
aggressively this game
um
h3 was a the proper move to play there
to prepare g4
but this is interesting too
h3 here probably just preventing knight
g4
attacking the knight
okay so gokul still hasn't won
let's take here
now this should be winning now
[Music]
the pawn was overworked
um not seeing it there
play this move attacking the queen
okay tournament's just about over
so this game's not counting for the
tournament
uh oh no my knight
but i'm gonna try and finish strong
okay so i guess i i survived
not sure how goku ended
i guess his last game didn't count yeah
i was running a fork
um i guess maybe i'll trade
i'll trade knights and try and open the
g file for the rook
also thanks to everyone who played i'll
do some wrap up i guess after
after this game
so the rook's tied down to the pawn
this isn't so simple a knight g2
ugly move
now this is not what i wanted this is
going to take a lot of work
because there's no mating attack unless
my knight gets in
which is maybe a possibility
or maybe not
okay i want to play this move
even though this game doesn't count for
the tournament it counts for raiding
and this is getting close
bishop will come here now
that bishop does a nice job defending
and attacking
where's the meat threatening this
okay now that looks pinned
oh
not seeing the meat
no
no ah i got dirty flagged ah
oh i saw i pros at the end there
thinking i was gonna flag my opponent
and the rook got captured
there goes my reading good game bob life
well played well this is a sad
celebration
it's a sad confetti it's like the
spelling bee
champion from that one year anyway
um thanks to everyone who played the
game
uh or the the tournament i should say
and played many games um
yeah i i still might uh i'll probably
post the whole tournament on youtube
why not had some fun games
congratulations gokul finishing in clear
second
and zanbato finishing in third
yeah i hope people enjoy that in the
future i'll probably do
more of these like viewer tournaments
nice way to get people involved
733 players it's not bad for
having like a impromptu event